[Musique]
bienvenue dans encore vous l'émission
qui reçoit des personnages que vous
savez forcément déjà vu au ciné ou à la
télé mon invité d'aujourd'hui est une
habituée des films d'aventurés en milieu
tropical elles bravent tous les dangers
certains mortels tribus hostiles mauvais
scénario de comédie mais toujours avec
un choix de chaussures audacieux je
reçois la femme en talons dans la jungle
femmes en talons dans la jungle bonjour
bienvenue dans mon corps me merci je
suis ravi d'être assise battre ici alors
justement si vous permettez on va
revenir un petit peu sur ce parcours
escarpé souvent moite rarement avec une
boussole
pourquoi la jungle je crois qu'elle est
racontée donc qu'est-ce qui a fait que
vous lancez comme ça à corps perdu dans
la forêt amazonienne à des jeux pour
voir si j'étais une femme c'est
peut-être le dernier endroit où je
mettrai les pieds
en fait qui se passe c'est qu'à chaque
fois qu'un aventurier par voulait un
artefact sacré un peuple colonisé pour
les mettre dans un musée sans
autorisation eh bien il embarque avec
lui dans sa quête est comme moi je ne
suis pas du tout équipés ben je me
retrouve à me plaindre a crié devant des
feuilles d'arbres parce qu'elle
ressemble à des insectes la godille
genre escarpins
vous en souffrez ben déjà physiquement
oui parce que je sais pas si vous avez
déjà essayé de fuir un tigre avec des
talons de 12 mais franchement et puis ce
qui est la représentation de la femme on
va en parler de ses chaussures moi je
tenterai de me dire j'ai voix de peter
très belle elle a pas de souci mais il
ya plus pratique quand même vous
cherchez un peu non je cherche pas du
tout c'est juste que à chaque fois
qu'une aventure marie va chier en plein
milieu d'un show burlesque connaît une
réunion professionnelle oui mais si
j'avais le temps d'enfiler des baskets
on pourrait très bien voir que chez tout
aussi capable de marcher que le héros
attendons beaucoup vous rendez compte
que vous êtes en train de vous dire là
c'est à dire vous n'aurez plus besoin de
lui pour marcher oui non je ne crois que
je me débrouille très bien tout seul
depuis que j'ai un ami qui s'ouvre est
il du coup qui protégerait thil qui
embrasse rettig à la fin du film un
papou un corps soyons sérieux et c'est
pour ça que je me sens toujours comme
une andouille a le cul des ébats encore
heureux quand même voilà mettez vous un
peu sa place et moi qui est la mienne
[Musique]
maintenant vous devez avoir l'air à la
fois effrayée est totalement ridicule
et n'oubliez pas que la plupart du temps
vous êtes écrit par un album aux mesures
moeurs du changement d'état page et
chaud geffroy aimez moi laissez moi mais
tout en restant sexy mais
non ça c'était ont d'ailleurs préféré
laisser mois terminés quand je pense que
je vous ai écoutés et que ça fait
maintenant une heure nous sommes en
train de faire des guignolade qu'est ce
qu'il ya ça me démange c'est pour dire
bonjour en zoulou
mon dieu allez je vous en supplie faites
me sentir d'ici
à ça vous change de vos réunions
tupperware à la ville vous avez raison
c'est très pénible
souhaité deux semaines j'ai des grands
pieds mais c'est la sienne
huawei c'est moi ok